Tonight you will be enjoying White Tiger
prepared three ways.
There's a whole pack of those milky white
a**holes breeding up on the fourth floor.
Anyway, enjoy.
Bon appétit.
Give me back those keys.
Hey, if it wasn't for me, you would be a
starving corpse right now.
Listen, neither one of us made it pretty far
on our own. So instead of us trying to get,
holy sh*t, the steak is good.
Instead of us trying to stab each other in
the back, we should put our heads together
and figure out how the hell we're going to
make it through this show.
Is anybody getting through to you?
Blink twice for. Yes.
Cool. We're f***ed.
Tonight I will be presenting a one man play
entitled 'That's In-Room Entertainment'
based on the hotel's in-room entertainment.
Hi, I'm Deborah from Guest Services and
welcome to Nevada.
Deep in the heart of Vegas is the Monte
Cristo, a veritable oasis in the sand?
And don't forget about our promenade.
It features all the latest brands and is
just a stone's throw from the salon girl.
Might be time to take care of those split
ends. And for all you lovebirds out there,
Las Vegas is still the marriage capital of
the world.
Time for kisses.
And you?
Have selected Express Checkout.
Please leave your key at the drop box at the
front desk.
And thank you.
For staying with us.
Well, we've come to the Q&A where I ask the
queues or I kick your A.
So now is the moment of truth.
What do you think?
Oh. Um.
I loved it.
What exactly did you love about it?
Your performance. I was moved.
It was what it was a tour de force.
I am in a tour de force this machete down
your throat.
If you're not going to tell the truth, then
I'm going to make you shut up and bleed.
It was a f***ing snooze fest.
Now you talk.
The hell did you say?
It sucked. Your performance was dull as
dishwater and frankly beneath you.
And you, do agree with her?
Yes, I agree with her.
Come on, man. It was boring.
I get it. You've been here forever, but you
did a play about a hotel.
But didn't Mark Twain say you should write
what you know?
Mark Twain is a dumb ass. You got to get out
in the world, man.
Yeah. Look, trust me, you don't want to spend
the rest of your life alone.
You end up talking to a car.
Yeah. Like this guy.
You know what? You're right.
I can't wait here for my audience.
I need to get out there and hunt my audience
down.
Oh, no, no. That's not what I meant.
No, that's exactly what you meant.
I'm gonna get out there, and I'm going to
embrace the chaos.
Who knows?
Maybe I'll even fall in love.
The show is going on the road.
That was beautiful, man.